yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is hah gay okay don't have white
against them usually I really would like
to see a statistic that's probably it's
probably crazy if it i feel i have
always got black okay so i don't know
what he's doing here does he play the
bank oh no I place that kilo spinone
some whatever playing here i usually go
with g3 but i don't know if i want to do
that after g6 probably not more angling
for some samish style set up I wonder
hmmm split going nite age five and l5
here early on it's probably playable I
[Music]
wants to trade the dark squared Bishop
here okay I don't actually mind this all
that much
yeah I mean not a big deal i think what
i still am more space here training
queens I like this position for white
maybe just not want to trade that's
possible check no yeah this is just a
thing slightly better for white
disposition let's see ya g4 is an idea
very direct also FYI think I go air for
seems like he does not mind this
position at all I think I have good
chances here long term with h3 ng4 will
take a while that it will materialize
okay so let's bring this to e3 normal
plan note that it's not so easy for him
to play because the night only three
attacks f5 and as long as this attack is
on it cannot move this Bishop one is not
be eight don't know of a six was such a
great idea we'll see um okay it still
cannot developed and h4 doesn't do much
okay this is a useful move anyway let's
do it I wonder if I can actually try
this is really awkward f this F five
foot porn always need some protection
maybe you should get the King there but
that doesn't really fit with room to g7
not easy m-maybe b6
for black and then look a 750 to at
least use two roofs looks awkward I have
a very simple idea here Knight to c3 a
five nights a 496 and black resigns
admittedly he can play moves in the
meantime so it's not that bad okay I'm
still curious to learn what he's doing
so be sexy em on this and then and I
think I'm threatening a 5 m and n 5 I
was a strategic threat maybe he had had
no way to prevent it that's that's
possible it just--whoop things I guess
it seems that is he tries to double I
always have 92 though now then I'm
better on the queenside i think i can
actually do this it's a little bit
strange to play that move
I can I can I can even wait until he
goes there and knowledge for so yeah the
King site now is close but I'm better on
the queenside King c3 and before as my
idea he still cannot move here as a five
is always a gay always attacked so may
even this is a good move
you
trying to trade off his only active
piece somewhat active piece on before
that's very awkward Bishop d7 I can take
and I'm ready for 94 winning at five but
not even clear how you should prevent
that maybe it'd still be sure to sound I
don't know other moves I don't see move
here for black
so if I go before is going who could be
seven yeah still good I think and now
King c3 just cover everything whenever
it takes on before it opens up 94 which
will be near five so this is a big issue
so between now threatening to take on c5
check that's more than a win and I t4
immediately you're on yeah no reason not
to his Queen side cannot move average
that's kind of funny
[Music]
yeah now he decides to sacrifice this
stroll him a threat in 97 him jack okay
that was beyond repair black resins the
the starting point is already here when
he very very willingly went up to the
structure and this is already quite
quite questionable for black he is
sitting with those pawns and they are
weak and I always have g4s the idea the
computer is still not super convinced
okay 0.64 white yeah probably this is
about right it's probably not more than
that and I think it got worse when he
inserted a sixth sense when 9 a-6 was a
potential way of at least developing and
I with the porn on a six it's not going
to happen I actually I think here at
night f6 maybe I should have played a
five-year it okay this is not bad the
mediate yeah the engine is actually very
right here I should go away five i
played this it is a normal regrouping
but in fact really a 5-4 black it looks
kind of poor to play that but it is
really clearly better in comparison then
what we got in the game when ultimately
i played 85 after he went b6 he should
have I should have played a five earlier
basically any move here yeah yeah no
it's I should go hukum this and I should
play a 50 kg fry is also given as good
which is kind of remarkable don't quite
understand why why this is so good your
night at five is going to be whoa okay
yes and he's down a couple of pieces
here in terms of development ok so that
was even better but I think I always
kept good
sure others would be quite surprised at
the engine might be five or so mediately
winning okay yeah I was just looking for
for for for strategic you play you think
surprise here now g4 really that's that
should be equal no come on that said
that's this I cannot believe it why
should this be equal I go before him
okay at least an advantage stop grunts I
still have a hard time to believe I'm
not clearly better here reason is that
the structure in itself is his favorable
for white anyway and he's got two trucks
stuck here to bit weird and now the
evaluation goes up a little bit at least
97 Bishop waveform this is this check
this is the engines line one white is a
lot better here looking to deform the
bishop still completely sucks he might
hold it but it's not if it's not fun
yeah the game this is just just pretty
awful check you don't everything falls
apart yeah there were little ways to
improve with the general structure i
think is pretty questionable for black
ok guys thanks for watching